foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York damning New allegations about
the sex scandal star at the BBC now the
presented faces claimed that he managed
a second young person and the BBC's top
boss admits he still haven't even spoken
to his star man as the BBC turned a
scandal into a full-blown crisis and is
it time for the presenter to reveal his
own identity
also tonight is foul mouth to raids as
media monster Logan Roy made him a
global Megastar and succession actor
Brian Cox has some logan-esque views on
the end of that show and the state of
the world it's a brilliant interview and
he joins me here in the studio
plus Hollywood actor Jonah Hill sex x
leagues intimate text messages in a bid
to prove he's a misogynist trigging a
battle of the sexes in the court of
public opinion Michaela Peterson joins
me live to give her blistering verdict
[Music]
live from New York this is his Morgan
uncensored
well good evening from New York and
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored live
from the Big Apple the more we learn
about the Scandal rocking the BBC the
Mercury it gets lawyers for the first
alleged victim say the claims are
rubbish the parents making those claims
accuse the BBC of lying
and they wonder how that their child who
they say is a crack at it can afford one
of the most expensive legal firms in the
country now after last night's
moralizing rush to judgment about the
sun's reporting damning new allegations
be made this time directly to BBC News a
second young person aged in their early
20s says the Maori presenter contacted
them on a dating app pressure them into
meeting in person then send menacing
abusive and explosive Laden texts when
they threaten to speak out what BBC News
has confirmed the messages were sent
from the presenter's phone the Scandal
feels like it's snowballing undoubtedly
more claims will be made possibly as
soon as this evening and at the heart of
his crisis are BBC leaders in total
disarray it's now clear that the parents
behind the first claim made a formal
complaint on May the 19th to the BBC but
only when the sun put the claims to the
BBC seven weeks later was the presenter
even told about them and what about the
BBC so-called investigation over the
course of those seven weeks attempted to
contact the family just twice once with
the pro former email saying we take your
complaints seriously and once with the
phone call which didn't even connect
well director General Tim Davey who
moves so quickly to suspend Gary lineker
but tweeting criticism of the government
was told over the coals today by one of
his own journalists
the team saw them as serious allegations
okay which which seems so weird as to
why the presenter was only spoken to on
the ones let's talk about that for a
minute because I think that is a really
important point which is if you've got
an allegation coming into a corporate
investigations team
and I think you need to balance the
concerns of Duty of care privacy all
those things I've talked about
I don't think you take that complaint
direct to a presenter if you just work
that through if anything that comes
through or any call that hasn't been
verified just gets bought in front of
someone yeah but there were only two
attempts made to contact the family one
by email one by phone does that is that
seem fine to you I think one things I
said today is I think that is a fair
question
well it's a very fair question isn't it
as is the question of whether Tim Davey
is up to the task of running the BBC
incredibly he's still not met or even
spoken to his star presenter at the
heart of this Scandal which is
decimating the reputation of the entire
BBC and you seem to determined to Fight
Fire with frankly what sounds often like
David Brent style management psycho
Babble well sure the beep I've given a
bit of context to a few people in terms
of the numbers of issues we get coming
into our corporate investigations unit
over six months that will be about 250.
and you take those and they are these
serious complaints that are coming
through of all all different types
and what happens is we have a
outstanding corporate investigations
team they're very experienced
really outstanding seven weeks and did
nothing the BBC gets loaded in place
nobody questions that it's a big company
but how many of those complaints were
serious as this one about one of the
BBC's most famous presenters it was
alleged to have paid 35 000 pounds over
three years for sexual images to a young
person perhaps criminally we don't know
yet beginning it said when he was 17. at
the same time his explosive claim was
festering the BBC's filing cabinets it
was providing viewers with breathless
wall-to-wall coverage of Phillip
schofield's demise at ITV another very
famous male presenter accused of an
inappropriate relationship with a
younger male colleague how could they
not see the severity of the allegations
and the urgency they demanded why did it
take the Sun newspapers reporting of the
parents claims for them to finally get
to work how can the public have any
faith that the BBC will handle these
shocking new claims properly and while
this crisis rages on the BBC and the
presenter involved are still leaving
other male stars to defend their own
reputations presenters like Gary lineker
Ryan and Clark and Jeremy Vine have all
been disgracefully smeared into famed by
armchair detectives who don't understand
the devastating impact it has Nikki
Campbell addressed this head-on
it was a distressing weekend I can't
deny it for me and others falsely named
today I'm having further conversations
with the police in terms of malicious
communication and with lawyers in terms
of definition
the situation is clearly untenable every
journalist and politician in Britain
knows exactly who his presenter is
increasingly members of the public know
who it is because of the way social
media behaves these days and more of
them will work it out by the minute if
you take a major star off air without
warning viewers will notice now I don't
know if the presenter has broken any
laws I do know his name they're a very
good legal and ethical reasons why I'm
not saying it like everybody else but
it's only a matter of time before he
loses agency in the situation somebody
blurts out in Parliament on a less
responsible network but the good of his
colleagues the BBC and himself and his
reputation it's surely time for that
presenter to reveal his own identity and
to vow to clear his name and defend
himself if that's what he can do well
joining me now it's former conservative
MP Louise Mensch here in New York with
me former BBC head of Ethics Akil Ahmed
and times radio host and former BBC
broadcaster John Pena all right um John
Pino you BBC man for so long what do you
make of this I mean yesterday it seemed
to be a squabble over the veracity today
this bombshell development of the BBC
themselves getting their own separate
complaint from a second individual about
this star presenter where do you see the
story going well look on the basis of
what we've seen and all I know is what
we have all all seen is it feels like we
are at something like a a Tipping Point
the situation yesterday it looked messy
enough it was clearly perilous for the
for the presenter it was kind of
embarrassing for the BBC and we heard
the director general of the BBC saying
today
um on in an interview and at that
briefing earlier on that this was
damaging to the BBC well how could he
say really anything else we had a
situation where allegations have been
made they were disputed they were
disputed firmly although very very
vaguely but a conflict of evidence and
now we have something more just
something having something more I think
begins to take the story into a
different a different dimension another
young person alleging effectively
abusive of abusive conducts a bit
expletive Laden emails in pursuit of an
attempt to date this young person using
a dating app it gets more and more
messing and reflects more and more I
think damaging me on the on the
presenter depending according to the
account that we've seen so far stress
again we don't know the ins and outs we
as as Miron Lookers of what went on here
fully behind behind the scenes but it
begins to feel like a Tipping Point and
who knows what comes next I mean John
you you know a lot of senior people at
the BBC what is the mood like there do
you think amongst other BBC presenters
it's the general mood that this
presenter at the center of this should
name himself and put this Feeding Frenzy
uh to bed by actually coming out and
talking about it openly as the person
fears are not there I'm again going by
what I what I see and read and what I
what I read into what I'm seeing and
reading and what I'm seeing and reading
this evening again suggests to me that
the situation is rather unraveling when
you have Jeremy Vine who is another
nationally nationally known broadcaster
calling publicly on this unnamed
presenter to name himself talking about
the BBC being driven I think the phrase
was being driven down to its to its
knees discussing this in terms of chaos
publicly for goodness sake on social
media one one high profile presenter
addressing another anonymous high
profile uh BBC presenter the thing is
coming apart of the scenes and that I
think you can imagine sure because I
certainly do imagine is just the tip of
of the iceberg although I use the word
iceberg ill-advisedly it's a lot hotter
than that I imagine at broadcasting
house
yeah Louise Minch um I watched or
listened to Tim Davy's interview on the
world at one today and it sort of it it
asked more questions by the end and we
got answers because you know he might be
in a difficult position here but the
idea that I think that the BBC took
seven weeks from the moment when they
were first told about these allegations
by this family to even alert the
presenter to this allowing him to
continue working but also that Tim Davey
still doesn't even talked to this
presenter who's one of the most famous
people in the country what is he waiting
for I mean that's surely everybody's
question what is he waiting for even to
be fair to the presenter and allow him
to clear his name the boss of the
corporation should be speaking to him
and saying what is your explanation for
this for these two complaints I would
even dispute from your account that the
BBC reached out to this family at all a
standard email saying we take your
complaint seriously is nothing more than
a piece of corporate spam it's not
really reaching and a call that didn't
connect and a call that didn't connect
yeah right okay your call didn't collect
on the sixth and then we hear from the B
species timeline that their
investigation remained open well I'm not
Inspector Morse but I don't know if many
people would call this an investigation
when you call the Family Once don't get
through and then just give up
you were the former BBC head of Ethics
clearly there are lots of ethical issues
here but I think the public generally
are pretty mystified about what's
happened here why if such serious
allegations are made against such a high
profile presenter why would the BBC
effectively do almost nothing the seven
weeks until a newspaper decides to run a
story
well it's not that they did nothing
obviously I mean look the thing to
remember is that the allegations we
don't actually know the nature of the
allegations when they were first brought
to the BBC we do know that there was a
conversation had a 29-minute
conversation and That Was Then escalated
up to the situation where they were
contacted now that's where we can have a
real serious conversation at some point
about whether or not those seven weeks
were too long and how much time was
spent but where as Tim Davey said
earlier on today 250 or so complaint
serious complaints that are investigated
in the six-month period that's a lot of
investigation and a lot of people so
there's not one person just working on
this and sitting there with a feet up on
the table they're probably looking after
lots of things but I do believe we do
need there will need to be an
investigation looking at that that time
frame and I think Tim Davey has said
that as well but with regards to the
allegations themselves and that we that
we don't know if there's any illegality
we know that there could possibly be
dependent on the age of the person
involved but I think what you have to do
how is a process the process we can
argue whether the process was any good
or not but there is a process in play
and Tim Davey as the Director General
you know he he can have a conversation
by all means but he cannot be involved
in the investigation because if this
gets to the extent where there are
sanctions which maybe even as far as
somebody losing their job and then there
was an appeal he probably is going to be
the person at that level who will have
to hear the appeal so we have to have
some honest conversations sometimes
about process we don't things can't just
happen in a nanosecond like like many
people I'm sure warriors on Twitter want
it to be but he's he's okay let me put
this to you you know for example I
remember
um Gary denica when he did his tweet
about you know refugees and you know
that was dealt with unbelievably quickly
so there's a tweet and bang bang well
you know he suddenly he's suspended I
agree with you about three nanoseconds
Danny Baker oh I agree with you that was
incorrect it was yeah Danny Baker was
taking off the Airways in micro seconds
after he did a very unfortunate uh tweet
um you know these people get treated
instantaneously there's no great long
investigations process here you have
incredibly serious allegations and the
presenter that they're alleged to uh
against is allowed to carry on a very
high profile job representing the BBC a
lot of BBC people I know are pretty much
sensed about that and for tickets
you can argue have whether or not the
investigation was any good but there was
an investigation happening which is very
different to the government can you hear
me I agree on the living conviction
never been taken off I can occasionally
can hear you he's dropping out in every
now and then
Akil I'm sorry we look we just lost you
briefly there um the point I was making
was I don't understand why why the boss
of the company wouldn't have at least
had some conversation with such a high
profile presenter about such serious
allegations before now and he still
hasn't it seems extraordinary to me and
I would imagine to most of the public
it probably does it depends on whether
or not there's going to be an invest it
depends on the investigation though
peers that's the problem because if you
are actually going to be investigated
and actually if you find this person
guilty of something and then that person
Appeals
who's going to hear the the appeal and
actually at the level that the
conversation has been had with we are
told with the individual that it
probably would be the director General
who may be the person who has to hear
that appeal so you have to keep yourself
away from the direct conversation it
feels weird and it's probably not what
Tim Davey wants to do to be honest with
you but it's probably what is being
advised and I've been in that situation
and it's frustrating for him I know it
will be
I mean I mean Louise you've the BBC's
bit the center of so many scandals
recently yeah the thing also that I
think about this one is that all this
was going on for the middle of May right
at the time the BBC was reporting
extensively on the Philip Schofield
Scandal over at the Rival Network ITV
and you would imagine that they would
all be much more aware and heightened
awareness of any potential incidents
like that in their own building that had
to be dealt with well he was a massive
one brought to the table that had just
done nothing about I completely agree
and you have to say which young person
matters when it's a young person that's
allegedly being put upon by an ITV
presenter or some other chance presenter
then we're going to cover it to excess
but when it's one of our own um when it
was one of our own and there's a lot of
allegations in the press that this man
is well liked at the BBC that he is
friends with a lot of the Senior
Management and this may have influenced
how it's been dealt with I mean I can't
really agree with what's just been said
because after all Tim Davey said users
words like we have a duty of care to the
presenter what about the duty of care to
this family who are desperate for your
help with a clearly vulnerable young
person who may or may not have been
under the age of 18. also I think the
BBC is giving the impression by saying
oh we only just got told that it might
have been under 17 the family denies
that the BBC is giving us the impression
that it will only look at its presenters
if they commit a criminal offense when
it's young people involved there's no
ethical consideration here just was it
criminal or was it not criminal most
people in this country are going to
think that people that we look up to
have a duty of care that goes beyond
simply don't commit crime and also this
second story which is not from the Sun
but has actually been reported by BBC
News investigating their own presenter
in the middle of their own Scandal
they've now revealed a second story
involving a second person which may well
indeed pass the threshold of a crime so
there's an irony there that this may not
have started with let's assuming the Sun
never said it was a crime by the way to
be completely upfront about what the sun
did it was actually I think the Sunday
Times when they reported it who pointed
out if the boy was if the person the
incentiviz was was uh 17 that there may
be a potential crime yes well I think if
the BBC had bothered to really speak to
him follow up the first complaint and if
they had in fact gone to the presenter
and asked them for his side of the story
and said are there any more of these out
there they might have had a heads up on
the phenomenal story that's just broken
tonight which is that a young person in
their early 20s is accusing the same
presenter of abuse of threats of
harassment there's never just one Mouse
Pierce there's never just one mouth no
and I hear there may be more Revelations
coming ladies tonight and we'll keep an
eye on that Louise great to talk to Akil
Ahmed thank you very much John Pena
thank you very much we're on Thursday
next tonight Logan Roy in real life
Brian Cox joins me for what is a truly
great laugh out loud interview you're
not going to want to miss this stay with
us
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Morgan I'm censored in New York City
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored in
Kiev Ukraine tonight on Piers Morgan's
special edition tonight a special
edition appears more than uncensored
Martina navratulations you believe you
can win this
are you gonna run again I think a lot of
people are going to be very happy yes I
feel betrayed they're trying to force
you out yes not only the coach but the
other two or three guys there around all
these people protesting just don't get
it many of them don't it's not slightly
patronizing
I would call it
psychiatric assessment I'd be there for
weeks did you keep quiet I'm trying to
read a book
thanks bear and Chuck it where it
belongs in the bin
sexy where are they where's their
children
why isn't someone else
it's from that much cushier jail that
Elaine Maxwell agreed to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him you're shaking your
head the British people are up in arms
Boris Johnson is out as British prime
minister the conservative party can
certainly win the next election can we
yes
this is the royal tea question is did he
say yes I have taken drugs and they bent
the rules to give them the Visa or lied
on the visa application form and
therefore got it
[Music]
what does a woman make
[Laughter]
it let it roll a woman is given to the
man in marriage Andrew You're simply
wrong I've been a terrible liar that's
true I mean would you be prepared to say
that I've been a terrible liar are you
sorry you said that
nothing it matters you should be
absolutely not you should be interview
adjourned
[Music]
which is your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving us Rhonda sanctimonious
or meatball Rock I've seen you clown
Tommy Fury so please go easy on me bro
please go easy you weren't asked to give
evidence to the grand jury I have
nothing to hire I'm the only one that
has been telling the troops if you had
to come up against a team and had a
Russian player would you shake that no
chance no chance it's life and death
it's
good what went wrong she said well I've
only got two years and I said you'll
have two months if you carry on like
this what's your response to him the
whole nation deserves
you don't drink another taken drugs
you're stinking Rich should we be
concerned
real opinions real debate is about you
and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that was a joke
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook and sensored
live from New York City you're looking
at Times Square there uh and earlier I
had the Fantastic Brian Cox in here you
may remember that Logan Roy's tongue
lashings in succession they brought a
global Superstar he's the Titanic Mogul
of course was a glittering career who
put the worlds to riots and scared the
living daylight instead of his enemies
and his character in the show is quite
something too well Brian join me I could
say earlier for riveting one-on-one it
was absolutely hilarious and a full of
his well extremely uncensored opinions
on the hit show on his career on
Politics on family on death on just
about everything here's Brian Cox
uncensored Brian great to see you here
in New York you have a place so you
spend a lot of time here well my family
or my my boys are here they're I I would
they're American that's what they have
to be you know my youngest is currently
in Thailand and is about to go to
Emerson College and my eldest of the
second family he's at the Atlantic
theater school and he's now directing a
project for the summer so uh and my
wife's here so but I'm about to go back
to England because I'm going to be doing
work for me with your kids have you got
the succession sorted yes yes they get
nothing
the one thing I've learned is don't give
them anything
they ask you because
I'm quite a debate where a lot of people
think of you give the kids nothing
others take of you give them something
others spoil them ridiculously how have
you actually been as a father in that
regard
I I think I'm fair I I think that you
know it's you know I've been a father at
different Financial stages in my life
you know I mean there's a time when I
was you know I had a very my first wife
was very smart with money so I was quite
good at that uh we're not so smart with
money on this side but we're doing much
better I actually on my on my WhatsApp
chat uh with my three sons in their 20s
I often send them Logan Roy gifts as
responses to their various observations
about what I should be doing to help
them I I love the way you say
observation I mean their needs yes
demands demands yes exactly let me ask
you I mean post succession
is it a weird feeling when you come out
of something that's so iconic so
successful why is a bit weird I mean the
problem is that uh I can't go anywhere
now I mean I I used to Pride my
anonymity but it's gone even here in New
York was they sort of used to oh yeah I
mean I go wherever I go somebody will
come up and say can I have a picture or
can you tell me uh you know what you
know and and I go okay um you can you
can and it's the best thing to say to
somebody because in a way you mean it
it's just the most famous you've ever
been in your life yeah I I think so and
do you like that I mean is it well
intoxicating but also a little bit
intimidating it has it it it's a sort of
what is it how do I describe it
it's a sort of
it's all right but it's also sometimes
gets a little bit over much you know I
mean you know because people are so
they're so into the show I mean it's
just incredible I know it's kind of
weird when I went to China I was in
China recently and I thought oh this is
great you know nobody will be nobody on
another show it lasted a day really a
day even there Logan Royal and that
suddenly all these kids
[Laughter]
and uh you know it's kind of strange and
I thought oh God you know but I mean
people are always I have to say people
are always very nice they're always very
graceful and you get the odd kind of
your budgie guy that comes in or says
it's gonna have it you know and you go
no coolant and I've learned the one
thing I have to I've learned and I've
never been good at this is saying no
I've had to learn how to say no on
occasion where are your limits
well my limits you want to just gets too
much you know or when it's when we're in
a particular area like getting off a
plane and somebody says can I and I'm
going well there's a lot of other people
if I start giving you I know the world
and his wife is going to start coming up
and wanting a photograph and I'm never
going to get to baggage
the the ending of succession the final
season I gotta be honest with you when
they killed you off I was incredibly
disappointed I thought it was not alone
well and I read then that you were well
I was I mean
I I wasn't really disappointed I mean I
trust Jesse Armstrong implicitly and
it's his decision and I want her to go
with his decision and that was fine I
understood it uh I think personally it
was a little quick I think I think they
could have given up but I think they
wanted that Sudden Impact which is what
it got yeah you know and that amazing
episode which I never watched by the way
you've never seen it no really why
well the idea of watching myself dying
on a on a plane is not really my idea of
fun you know it's not something I really
want to take on board you know oh you
know I just watch myself die a lot
so dramatic and so good and I was so
overwhelmed by my dad and bollocks to
that
I know you know I mean it just you just
go yeah you know and people kept
somebody would say did you watch the
episode I said no why not it's a great
episode I said I'm sure it's a great
episode but I know there's no way that
I'm gonna watch myself Ania or um lying
on a you know on a cop on a plane
funny enough I watched it and after that
the next few episodes it began to lose
me because you weren't there because
Logan Roy was no longer part of it I
began to lose interest and I tweeted to
that effect and then got a whole
Maelstrom of response from people and if
you'll probably hate this but I got back
into it when your coffin appeared in the
in the funeral scene yeah yeah because
suddenly you were back and then of
course there were some amazing
performances but the other characters
were then responding because you were
there again yeah I felt that quite
viscerally as a as a fan of the show
yeah I mean yeah I was I mean that was
also a very funny thing to happen
because they were worried about the
funeral and they kept saying you know uh
you know we we don't want to give it
away we've got to keep it you know when
it was over
really over in the last episode ad and
that's the end of succession what were
your honest feelings about that
when I my honest feelings is I'm I was
incredibly proud to be part of such a
an extraordinary show and really uh kind
of groundbreaking in many ways because
it's a satire and it's brilliantly
written mainly by British writers who
know how to do that thing of edge they
get that sense of Edge and certainly
Jesse does and I trusted them completely
I mean one could quarrel and say you
know it's all I mean there's all I mean
you get all kinds of things which are
stupid like sensibly oh I've been
rejected because I'm they're killing me
off but of course it's called succession
yes you know he's got to go sometime
it didn't make it I hate to ask you this
because it sounds a bit morbid but when
you go through your own death in a drama
like that as an actor does it make you
think more about dying
I've always thought about dying I mean
yeah I mean you know I lost my father
when I was eight so death has always
been kind of omnipresent in my life so
I'm and I've lost you know my sister my
older sister it just passed away in
February so I I'd experienced that and
ironically you know Logan's death is
quite funny because I was never there
how do you follow something like
succession
Christ knows
I mean you know how do I follow is this
what your bank managers asking exactly
exactly they're all going and now what
you know could you imagine retiring or
not me yes never no no no I don't
believe in that no I'll go on to I drop
would you would your dream be in in
mid-performance no no no no no might
might not be a sort of wind down I think
slowly I think eventually the the
dementia will get me
I think I think I'll be and then it'll
be nice to be able to say well I can't
do it anymore I've got it I'm hoping
that I can keep dementia at Bay for a
bit longer I'm still you know I'm not
old just bring chicken I'm a spring look
at me I look quite well you do it very
well actually I know you do look very
well I know I think I look amazing for
my age I mean how old are you now I'm
77. are you really yeah you you look
great I know
well it says the next ball from my
interview with Brian Cox and he's got
some uncensored views on the state of
the world on canceled culture on trigger
warnings and who should be leading the
labor party
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to piersburg Wisconsin live
from New York there's Sixth Avenue for
you buzzing with activity at this time
of the afternoon well now for my part
tip of my interview with actor Brian Cox
we discuss the future of British and
American politics including who he
thinks should be the next leader of the
labor party and his thoughts on the race
for the presidency here in the United
States plus his views on wokery
does it help with your anger management
about global politics right now ah yes
it adds to it
you know it makes me more and more it
gives me uh somewhere to get my vent I
mean I shouldn't think it's difficult
because both in the United States and in
the UK I mean there's a lot of
Mayhem going down let's talk I would say
there's a lot of crap going down quite
frankly I was going to use that word
let's talk about America first but it
does seem extraordinary that we're
reaching a position where potentially
the next election is Biden V Trump again
in a population of 320 million people
yeah it's all pretty horrible it's all
pretty horrible really and it's been
really I think
living under that four years was such a
strain I mean it really was and we were
here I mean I'm convinced that I think
Jesse and the writers got really
exhausted by that you know it was very
interesting because on the first of
first read-through of the show
when we shot the first pilot was the day
that Trump was elected was it really
yeah and everybody was going back to see
Trump well to see uh Hillary elected and
I knew when you see Biden he's only a
little bit older than you I know when
you see everybody Iran uh yes he did
actually he died anymore no no but I
mean when you when you see him you know
falling over and tripping and all the
verbal gaps and so on like I say I mean
you don't do that and you're 75 it's so
funny I was at the doctors this morning
and they kept saying do you have to help
yourself up when you stand
you know are you able to how can you
deal with the curb I was being asked
this question I said this is like I'm
pumping big weights I can move on a girl
let's turn to the UK you're going back
to the UK to do this this production in
bath and then and moving to the West End
we've had a nightmare haven't we Boris
Johnson the chaos Liz truss not
outlasting a lettuce uh Rishi soon act
certainly he's brought a little bit of
decency back I think in terms of the
weekend Ducks himself but the Tories
seem in big trouble Nicholas sturgeon of
course four starred in Scotland and then
being arrested and so on I think that's
a bit of a Witch Hunt quite honestly do
you I do I really do I think that she's
been made a scapegoat there's something
going on there which is you know she's
been arrested why would she be arrested
well in connection with the financial
and proprietary charges against asthma
yeah but it's but but they were all
dropped they lasted you know it's like
after two hours they were unarrested so
why didn't they arrest him in the first
why didn't they question whether they're
arresting them I mean all of it's so
dodgy quite honestly I mean you know who
would who would have it in for a to that
degree do you think
it's hard to know it really is hard to
know but I do think that there's a real
there was a real worry about it and
especially the vulnerability of the
Tories at the moment but also the
vulnerability of the labor party I mean
I know kirstama doesn't want to have
anything to do with that
with uh you know Independence Scottish
independence he really is absolutely
again but you see I think what's
interesting in in the UK is the work
that somebody Andy like Andy Burnham has
done in Manchester yeah how that is
really working and how those cities like
Liverpool and Manchester really and all
you have to do is join them up and
suddenly you've got a kind of autonomous
group that are really con you know being
incredible but uh why is this such a
paucity of Leaders with a really Fierce
moral compass a capability to bring
people with them and to really affect
change well I think the the problem is
that they get marginalized you know I
mean I think Andy Burnham is a case in
point I mean he's to me he's the perfect
leader of the labor party should be no
question are you a cricket fan bruh I
admire it but I'm Scottish I know so who
do you want to win out of England
Australia
oh I like England to Wing really oh and
Scots wanted whoever beats
this idea that we do I mean I'm an
anglophile you see I'm my view uh Pierce
is I don't want to see I mean I love
England I love the United Kingdom and in
a way when you look at it you look at
the map and you see you know you see
Scotland England Wales Ireland Northern
Ireland and I've always thought that
really what we need is not a United
Kingdom we need a United Federation we
need a we need a situation where each
country is autonomous and they come
together as a group so that we we have
to understand our reality but at the
same time we want to be independent we
want to be make decisions for ourselves
we're grown-ups and I think the United
Kingdom to me is finished there were a
few stories recently where I actually
immediately thought of you and thought I
could almost hear the steam coming out
of your ears one was that there's a new
theater production of The Sound of Music
where there are literally warnings to
audiences because they say the musical
touches of Nazi Germany and the
annexation of Austria that an audience
now has to be warned about The Sound of
Music well this is what I mean this is
what I can't stand
I can't stand the way we want to rewrite
history I can't stand the way we don't
want to acknowledge history and it's so
important to acknowledge what our
history is because that is defines who
we are and where we've got to and
without an acknowledging history we are
screwed you're well and truly screwed
and I think we've not done that nearly
enough but all these trigger warnings
that people want to put now on Art
whether it's books poetry films and
theater Productions whatever it may be
when do we get so sensitive so overly
offended are we or is it other people
deciding we ought to be I think it
really is about other people deciding we
ought to be I don't think we are I don't
know anyone and it goes to Sound of
Music he needs to be told by the way
there are references to Nazi Germany I
mean ridiculous I I I find that I don't
I don't know where that's coming from I
really don't I want to know who's making
those I think it's a small number of
people they it gets whipped up by a sort
of very woke mob on social media before
we know it this becomes standard
practice then you start seeing all the
books having great chunks well you know
you we had the whole thing with Roald
Dahl yeah you know which is disgraceful
it's ridiculous it absolutely
disgraceful I mean Roald Dahl is a you
know he was a difficult man but he wrote
some amazing stuff but if the criteria
for canceling people or or revisiting
everything they do was being difficult
you would wipe out almost every artist
of any note in history yeah they're all
a bit difficult exactly in Charles
Dickens boom boom you know and you go
it's not on it's just simply not on and
it's the you see it also comes from
complete ignorance it's a it's an
ignorant state that creates this sort of
oh that that's bad that's good yeah I
mean it's ridiculous to say of course
you know that's what happened Michael
Shane recently said he says that
non-welsh actors playing Welsh
characters he found hard to accept what
do you think of that
I want to depends I I I don't find it
hard to accept that they can do the work
I mean I played knife Bevan you know I
played Nye Bevin I'm a Scott I played I
was I played a Welshman how was your
Welsh accent very good can we have a no
I'm not gonna
I'm not a performing monkey
come on Brian look you
I don't agree with Michael machine that
and I don't believe you know I don't
believe in having I know I mean if a
Scottish person if a non-scotish person
can do the Scottish thing I'll buy it so
if I was to suddenly take up acting and
play William Wallace you'd be fine with
that if you were any good
I mean if you were I would
certainly
on that bombshell right great to catch
up with you love it really I really
appreciate it and best of luck with your
Productions back in the UK good to see
you
If Only They were all like Brian Cox you
can watch the full uncensored interview
with Brian on the Piers Morgan
uncensored YouTube page from now Ron
says the next tonight Michaela Peterson
joins the beers back to pass judgment on
what's been called Jonah Hill's
emotionally abusive text to his former
wife it's Battle of the exes next
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk fresh allegations
against the star at the center of the
BBC Scandal is revealed in the sum the
government's spending half a million
pounds a day on empty Hotel Beds to keep
them reserved for migrants and the Royal
Navy says teenagers are refusing to
serve on submarines because they can't
cope without being connected to tick
tock that's all at nine o'clock
[Music]
live from New York City where I have a
stellar peers pack right with miss
superpac you might call in fact I'm
joined by podcast host and influencer
Michaela Peterson Fox News contributor
Kat timp and Fox News Nation host tires
or welcome to all of you I feel almost
glittered by the stardusters around me
um but for some breaking news just
coming on that story that we started at
the top of the show with the BBC star
suspended over the sex claims has now
been accused in a new report by the sun
which broke the original story of
breaking the law by defying the third
National lockdown to meet a young
stranger from a dating site apparently
allegedly ignored strict covid rules
even though his own network was of
course providing Around the Clock
coverage of the pandemic so that's just
broken on the Sun
newspaper website so that will clearly
take the story into a whole new
dimension uh we're right let's start
with this pack now
that's nice for me Jonah Hill
emotionally abusing his ex Sarah Brodie
Michaela welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensor first of all as a newbie
um so what I've read I mean Sarah Brady
seems to be relentlessly posting all
their old text message exchanges which I
just don't think is on anyway one
secondly when I've read them all Jonah
Hill's perfectly entitled to just lay
down some boundaries isn't he and if she
doesn't want to go along with it well
fine and she clearly didn't really so
they spit up and that's it and they move
on but she won't move on and that must
shame him why well when I first read the
text I thought maybe Jonah Hill was
being unreasonable because if you're
going to date a surfer and they put up
swimsuit photos you can't be that
shocked by it but that was before I knew
that it was a year and a half later he's
just had a kid with his girlfriend so I
would just say she's she's looking for
attention obviously so he was probably
right about the swimsuit photos in the
first place being irritated by them
because it was probably for attention
given she won't give it up now but
because I mean why are we reading all
this I mean they spit up he's met
someone else he's become a father with
somebody else I read them they're not
like abusive abusive it's just him
saying I would prefer you don't do this
this kind of conversation goes on in
every relationship doesn't it yeah I
feel like now everything is has to be
some specific therapy word and yeah that
side or another he maybe was I think he
was being kind of a jerk in that
conversation don't start dating a surfer
if you're not comfortable with these
things but also yes yes and she's
clearly looking for attention because
she keeps posting more and more
and none of us I don't care who you are
none of us would look awesome
based on our worst text we've ever seen
I mean I would but Cyrus uh nobody wants
to see their dirty linen airing on
Instagram stories minute by minute she's
posting this stuff all day long well to
be fair she's posting excerpts yes of
the text she's not posting her stuff
because typically if since she wants to
use big words like abuse because abuse
has changed a lot because I need to call
some of my football coaches and I have
to bring them on this show because they
didn't talk to me that way about
boundaries and if you don't like you do
it my way they use cuss words and stuff
so the sensitivity of this is basically
um just she's just coming off looking
really thirsty I mean she says in one of
the posts this is not abuse she said
this is a warning to all girls if your
partner's talking to you like this make
an Exit Plan love you all call me if you
need near well he made the Exit Plan he
set up boundaries but let's here's the
thing in the argument about the um she's
a surfer okay but Surfers usually wear a
wetsuit when they surf competitively she
was taking pictures and and Kat did this
great she did this great prank on social
media where she took a picture with a
black box by where her butt was and then
when you swiped it it was an even bigger
one so but there was no black box with
her she's the only bathing suit photo
that I have on the internet we're
talking about bathing suits let's talk
about Miss Netherlands at the weekend
Ricky Valerie uh Coley who was a
transgender entrant to miss Netherlands
competition uh won the title so a
biological male has been voted Miss
Netherlands and will now take part in
Miss Universe Michaela your thoughts I
hope he wins Miss Universe I'm I'm
kidding I'm kidding it it's I don't even
know how to react to these situations
because women fought so hard to get
where we are today I was just looking at
the picture of the Boston marathon
runner in 1967 and it's this woman and
she's being grabbed by men on the track
because women weren't allowed to compete
that's where it started and now we're
here and there are men competing in our
Sports and I have no idea how feminism
came full it is it is it's so bizarre
and Cat I mean Only Yesterday Megan
rapino one of the great female sports
stars in American history came out on as
she retired this might be convenient
timing because it won't apply to her and
said I'd be very happy if trans athlete
Sports women come and play in the
American women's team well fine but what
happens if they're all 11 biological
males representing the American women's
team I mean this can't be right surely I
think what's even worse is people saying
that if you have some issue with with a
biological male competing in sports then
the only reason for that is that you're
transphobic and not the research that
you can point to that shows that someone
who's gone through male puberty could
have various advantages over a
biological woman in these activities in
Esports it's not a zero-sum game when
it's these conversations there's
scholarships there's different things on
the line there and I think that that
really just taints the whole entire
issue when it comes to pageants I do
want to get on the record that I think
pageants are lame right I mean that
that's a pretty reasonable argument
they're all lame but Tara's you know
it's
it's me like every aspect of Womanhood
is for one of a better phrase under
attack from the trans Lobby that
basically want to have
their rights superseding women's rights
to just be competing against other
females now to be fair in my opinion is
going to be skewed because I am I do
identify as a phobic
phobic on everything so the idea that in
this what does it say about women that a
man can just switch and be a woman and
inside of six months win everything so
you know where are the feminists turns
out the feminists are the alpha males
because we're the only ones complaining
about this right and I think it's
whenever you always have to follow the
money whenever somebody comes out and
says I think this and doesn't make sense
with the soccer player
she I guarantee you if a trans man took
her job yes that would not be the
conversation oh it may happen it'd be
you know and it's just like the same
thing with like the Equal Pay thing when
you do the math they actually are making
more than the men so it just goes back
to narratives they say things there's no
way I don't care what makeup hair
whatever that any man to Transitions is
going to be more beautiful than a woman
it's just not Pageants the scholarships
the modeling jobs that go with it it's
political you you can't tell me like
that and I don't know that person could
be the nicest person in the world but
there's no way that is the best way of a
woman also when Megan rapino talks about
this she likes to position herself as
all about equality she fought a very
good campaign for the women players to
be paid the same as the men great okay
they get big audiences they're world
champions I can sign up to that but
what's equal about allowing people with
an obvious physical advantage to come in
and decimate women's sport it's not
equal so you can be you can be all about
equality right to the point you say this
stuff then you're not about equality um
talking of equal cat and we don't know
the answer to this question but Elon
Musk has challenged Mark Zuckerberg not
just to a cage fight but he's now up to
the ante he said Zuck is a cook I don't
know it means a is it you tweeted
Sunday night I propose a literal dick
measuring contest
speaking of differences and gender women
don't do this women are never like in a
business dispute and they're like oh
yeah we'll pull your pants down because
I got what I got going on is better than
you uh this is just him being a bro you
know I don't think they ever actually
fight in a cage match I think that Elon
Musk is having a little bit of fun with
this and I don't think they ever
actually do it because what do you make
of this whole threads thing 100 million
people have signed up in the space of a
few days I mean Mark Zuckerberg is
taking the challenge to to Elon Musk is
Elon Musk in trouble with Twitter do you
think
so 100 million people signed up in a few
days but there's 2.35 billion people on
Instagram I don't know if that type of
conversion at like five percent is
something to be that proud of and I've
been on the platform and
compare I don't think this is
interesting I guess that would be the
nice way of saying it I don't think it's
as interesting as as Twitter but also
Taurus I mean Zuckerberg's trying to
make it it's going to be a place for
nice conversation there is no social
media platform that's nice yeah they're
all vile aren't they all of them even
Facebook or it doesn't seem like lotion
in the basket type nice in the other
direction well I would like to argue no
women don't pull them out and put them
on the table so to speak but they're
always judging each other by the way
they're dressed and talking about
outfits
yeah but then look at her shoes
they're delicious they're not actually
getting no manner no no two no one's
going to pay money you see Zuck and Elon
no no
Absolutely I'll see the injuries I would
see the entrance I'm telling you right
now stage fright lights a lot of money I
wouldn't pay as much money as I would
pay currently to see Cats infantol which
starts next week oh yeah I'm announcing
even more dates on Thursday how many
days you doing
that's it from me Keep It Uncensored
good night
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]